avait ça qu'on voulait dire c'est ils
veulent que tu sois comme tout soit la
taille et à la le pouvoir selon la
légende question monde par la sagesse de
l'egypte ancienne et une blanche voit
derrière les avions des baisses des
produits chimiques
tous nos respects du sommet de morhange
signifie en grec le message et léviathan
pour qui nous asservissent bizarre toi
il exclut les collections cm-cic
ponctuent ça fait un peu microsoft
jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
pas ton posé je veux développer la
franchise mister freeze au maghreb on
sait pas ce que tu veux dans l'est
aujourd'hui des boulangers un autre
pompier et [ __ ] tu rends fou j'avais 8
ans pour l'argent la semaine prochaine
match dans ma mère à son boulot tamer el
harrach 1 tu les as pas jouer les
économies tu m'as fait ça que pour qui
on va monter introduites espagne je sois
toi frère et moi j'avais fait ça doit
remonter du vélo je vais prendre mes
démons med avec toi d'accord maintenant
je suis toujours invités
des couilles comme un des chouchous
il me bat maïmonide attaque enfin être
premier mais on avec ta mère non pour
moi ta [ __ ] faut qu'ils aient peur de
nous qu'on regarde assez précieux la vie
tu constamment parce qu'on veut nous la
voilà terroristes
maintenant
tu as bien fait de l'appeler est amer
je suis fier d'être devenu un projet n'a
qu'à
[Musique]